[音楽]
私はた方を20年近く狩りをしています
だからこんな風に言うに富んでいたりー
彼をする強いイメージがあるかもしれません
でも実はとても神経質で臆病でだからこそ慎重です
だが食べるためにいうものが必要で獲物となる生き物たちにもまた食べる生き物が必要
で
休むための場所がなければ生きていけず
巣作りする場所がなければ次の取材が生まれません
死ねばその体を動物や虫異生物が分解し
新たな命を育むことになります
中は誰かだけで生きていけません
私は1本の木が切り倒され伊藤氏が良くなるとあの木にどれだけの生き物が生かされて
いたのだろう
そのつながりを持ってしまいます誰かだったら寝床にしたかもしれない
巣を作ったかもしれない
夏に木陰で休んだかもしれないし獲物を探す
リハビリにしたかもしれません
みなさんの身近なところに生きる誰かが結構います
私の高田のほかにも山に入ってではなくて
身近なところでしています
私の高殿からないものは主にか元記事です
草や木が生い茂り鬱蒼とした瓦が護岸工事で綺麗になり
遊歩道になると
隠れればがなくなったかもはいつかなくなりました
だが彼もを食べた痕跡を見ることもなくなってしまいました
基準狙うときは両県と一緒です
記事は普段草むらなどを利用して身を守っていて
狩りをするとわかりますが
国が危なくなったらすぐに逃げようと生地が決めている曲村が数十メートル先にあり
ます
記事は早く取りますがあまり長い距離をそのスピードでは飛べない短距離選手なのです
ね
そのため2枚を複数持っています
言えばは長年放置され草木が生い茂った休耕田です
それが減ったためそれまで行った場所に生地がいなくなりました
20年前は歩くだけであちこちから記事が飛び出した場所は
今は了見が1日探して市は出るかどうかになりました
オス記事は朝や夕方あちこちでなぁ晴れの主張で泣いていますがその声もずいぶん減っ
てしまいました
記事が全くいなくなったわけではないのですが広い土地の中にポツポツだった急行デー
がなくなったことで道路業に続く草むらに移動したため
危なくていには誰かといないですし私の借りた無関係に記事自身が生活の中で車にひか
れている数が多くなったと私の知るとつでは体感しています
ん
道路で死んでいる野生動物って結構いますよね
いう結果は目にすることがあったとしてもその生き物がなぜどうしてそこで神なのか
その子には多くの人が思いもしない背景があるのかもしれません
これは北海道にあるもうキーねぇ学研究所で冷凍保存されているも大きい3たちの写真
です
すべて解剖し死因を探るため保存されています
この全てではないもののかなり多くの猛禽例が人の影響で命を落としています
関連し風力発電の無礼るで叩き落とされたもの
交通事故中毒死など
その背景の一端を私はこの約20年の会でて感じてきました
そしてそのことを多くの人に知ってもらうため漫画という形で発信してもいます
私のた方も狩場は減少しています
私の狩場な現象は野生のた形の狩場な芸小に通じています
だから自分の狩りではなく油性のた形が心配になるのです
例えば私の相棒であるをたか
基本的に大田区のカレーは待ち伏せ型です
費などいたマリ自分のせいだとお気に隠しながら周り見渡し
条件がそろえばそこからスタートです
私ども狩りであれば私はその木です
高尾腕に乗せることを据えるといいますが
これはただのせていればいいわけではなくてオオタカが止まって休む
お気に入りの木の枝になることを言います
そのために震えてもいけないグラグラしてもいけない
腕の角度が上がっても下がってもいけません
誰かがバランスを取ることに必死になってしまうからです
常に一定で安定していて
私という人間の存在を誰かが気にしない
押しれるほど出なければなりません
木にとまっている高木を気にしないように
そしてたかだけでなく獲物にとっても気にされない存在になります
その状態でおは誰かの射程距離もでもに設計しますが
野生の誰かの場合は私のような96者はいないのでその場の日常系をうまく利用し整形
しています
鷹狩りでは私は誰かにとって動く立地条件なわけですね
だから一条件環境がどれだけ高野刈谷生活に重要なのかが分かります
そのため大田区が身を隠し接近できる条件がそろっているかで景色を見ています
私が誰かと狩りをする時に私がしている役割をするものがその場にあるかどうかを見る
ということですね
そういうふうに景色を見ていると環境ごとば保っていかなければ無関係に見えたとして
も関係しているつながるようたち
生き物たちを追い込むとわかるのです
私は専門店に環境生物を学んだわけではありませんし成立多様性環境保全などの言葉を
後から知りました
でもそれが何を意味しなぜ重要なのかは誰かと壁をすることで体感してきたため
すんなり取り替えてきました
大きなことをしなくてもいいんです
だが少しだけ私たち人間と共に生きる生き物たち
環境気遣うことで私たちも変えていける
この分別素材お金することそれでもいいんです
もう金だけで言ってもシーンの第一が交通事故のもの思います
少し気持ちに余裕を持ってスピードを控えて運転するだけで接触せずにすむ生き物も
きっといいます
お隣さんとして近所の人に迷惑をかけないため
きっと皆さん気を遣いますよね
お隣さんである野生動物たちにもそんな気遣いを少しだけ持ってもらうだけで守れる
景色があると信じています
ありがとうございました
ああああああ
[拍手]